welcome to this video playing a 15
minute ppm DRC against a guy called
Robert Saunders from the UK there is no
name in them I wonder who is Wow is
played what 4,000 no this is crazy in a
way he played 4295 15-minute games wow
that's an amazing amazing count Wow ok
so the Queens gambit that took me 40
seconds to head to to digest this number
um yeah what does for that wasn't fear
if they really would last 30 minutes
it's like 2,000 hours of 15 minutes yes
this is like completely crazy okay um
let's see what line of the Queens gambit
we get black now as a wide choice can
play
yeah almost all of that don't blunder
material Bishop e7 Bishop before or c59
bd7 c6 takes on c4
this is the list of them lights with
them with another reputation maybe you
can even do odd things like a six
probably not totally terrible but okay
hard to guess what some blacks play here
it takes a while at least night bd7 yes
that's a let's move quite often played
against players to play the bishop for
line as some black and then can capture
and possibly hold on to the porn with
night to be 6 i'll just take here play
Bishop f4 and hope to get a good version
of them Queens gambit exchange cards but
black can play in something like c6 and
night h5 this is some quite a good setup
c63 night h5 something like that maybe
on c6 I'll go play age three well he's
taking us time ok 15 minutes and allows
for some longer things yeah the ideas if
he goes night h5 no I'm just dropping
back to h2 and my bishop is not
exchanged if I if I played III night h5
Bishop g5 Bishop e7 the exchange would
have been unavoidable maybe black could
consider a move like night to be 6
intending to play Bishop t6 to exchange
it
it could be an option but after Knight
b6 III bishop d6 I can also play 95 and
I probably will ok so just a normal move
and I'm fine on the clock if I get in
Bishop d3 Queen see two castles I'll
have a very good Queens gambit exchange
the bishop is actually better on air for
then on g5 it has more influence on the
queenside in this way and cannot so
easily be exchanged
yeah I expect Castle cm another
possibility um for black hair could be
night to f8 intending 92 g 6 and after
Bishop moved from f/4 to h2 for example
then Bishop to d6 this maneuver is a bit
slow though yeah he's going for it it's
slow but not necessarily bad hmm Jeff
interesting
Bishop d3 96 bishop age to push a d6 I
can play Knight to e5 ok oh I go for
that you don't want to exchange too much
the question is this Bishop g3 an option
i guess not no let's get all the way
back and now Bishop be success them the
logical follow-up ok so is maybe it's
just delaying it for a moment I go I'll
go guess what
oh maybe yes maybe this was Sir I know
sorry it wasn't it wasn't hmm my idea
was on Bishop d6 to play 95 a half so
it's may be preparing it interesting
yeah interesting very interesting
question well two two things are
interesting I can try to play for the
very classical minority attack with
before starting with a move like rook be
one or something like that if he goes
rupee you want bishop d6 I need to
exchange the bishop and then before it's
got 94 though so I'm probably need to
invest a further move with Quincy tool
I'm wondering what the most precise move
order actually is okay well this is one
general ADM go for B form the other idea
could be to play Knight e5 in exactly
this position now and then follow it up
with F form sort of playing in the
center and look on the queenside 95 and
f4 it makes the bishop on edge to look a
bit silly though okay I'll go for them
traditional play on the queenside i
don't know i don't like the idea of
playing f4 with the bishop on edge to it
looks a bit strange it's a different
matter if the bishop would be on g5 okay
so he's playing a couple of
strengthening moves or maybe he's really
trying to to sacrifice on h2 like Queen
moves and then Bishop a free it's very
hard to believe them another idea of
this should be six can be 94 because a 2
hangs like 94 night XD for DFO be sure
before Bishop takes a two this is some
possible way to play
still surprised that he did not flick an
8 a-5 no explain give a five isn't be 5
MLB five yeah okay on b5 we can place if
I but it's not not exactly grade if I
take it I need to check this as well if
i take it Queen air five is skating this
temp on the night so I probably advanced
Black Widow c5 I I suspect yes so I
don't want him to play c5c for so I'll
just take it
what now he's got the IQ p on d5 but
it's a very specific type of a QP
because of the Queen sides situation hmm
yeah I can play something like 93 to e2
to deform try to be a be good good and
solid in the center but it's not so
clear what it actually accomplishes I
wonder actually I go nite a fry will
probably drop all the way back now but
it's not really clear what a move like
94 does I could play Queenie for
covering from the side actually like
that DM covering d4 from the side I mean
and the lower maybe look FC one
let's rock FC one actually an idea is
just stupid yeah but I like I like it at
least I have sometimes I have the idea
of the play Bishop f1 securing against
all kinds of weird sacrificial ideas
yeah 92 I thought should be should be
okay I also always have a 3m kicking the
bishop bag oh that's a bit surprising
okay I'd like to put something on d4
let's do that I go with the e tonight
because I'd like to have some control on
c1 so that I may be can just exchanged
looks soon afterwards
if two is a slight weakness am here hmm
now that's not really great maybe what
can I do here maybe I can take here
actually Queen takes that is a three hmm
I was hesitating because that's also
maybe night x f2 a three-night x f2 well
take screen takes and I'm busted him so
I need them a defensive move against
that maybe I am I'll take it oh yeah
take care that's okay and if the rook
takes I go a 3 in Taegu and when 85
maybe Knight c3 but Knight takes bishop
takes rook see one looks like a pretty
awkward self pin
yeah bishop moves I'm taking a five I
guess yeah that's the mentioned a self
pin Bishop takes rook see one rook takes
I can take on 36 and then maybe okay
well here's rook see one looks you want
us to move anyway this is silly must be
right setting up this situation on the C
file I mean c8 is protected it's not
like it said it's a deadly pin like him
play that saber should have six or this
one okay he's threatening look see one
chick made almost so i probably have to
take on c aid check you know okay can I
take on a five just being just being
greedy if they give us check here Bishop
of one takes takes it is it seems
playable there's always the maid on d
aid
mmm you don't really see a drawback we
need five could see one check bishop
everyone is there something great that
black can do yeah maybe you can make
some room for the king like the H poem I
can't even play g3 though okay I'll take
it I don't see I don't see the problem
at the mood check your sugar channel
it's not it's not a maid of the back
rank how idiotic is that it just night
f8 oh wow yeah I'm playing like a
complete [ __ ] can just take H to take a
one Queen da check yeah okay wait maybe
maybe I can play Queen aah grab you some
but this was completely unintentional of
course I simply forgot about night of
eight wow wow yeah this should win for
black somehow
yeah I'm not quite sure what what he's
doing I can just take it here check okay
i can i can try that hoping for the the
be porn what what a game okay should i
take on no i don't think so on d5 and
each i need to be pawn that's the only
how only help him it is pretty quick
though it's not I maybe quince hmm not
sure where it's okay so cam
hmm the moment I don't term I don't see
a totally easy win for him which is
probably my own problem because I
overlooking all this in the first place
was pretty dreadful Queen here to
prevent the checks on the diagonal be h
2 h 2 and next to the beep horn runs i
don't i don't see at the moment what
he's doing against it
yes but I have to check here and he
needs to return then or here for draw at
least if i go here play b7 what is what
is he doing after that and threatening
to take and taiwan maybe there's even
something better there goes to see eight
for this chick yes at least a perpetual
check yeah I think it's this is probably
all right and then be seven
ok and now I'm threatening just Queen c7
and promotion I don't see anything I'm
just winning I believe yeah that's sick
that's really thick Queen ch well then
maybe he can get this perpetual in
quincy eight
I twin c8 Queen I got Queenie five check
now that sets a draw okay if I go Queen
a seven check this may be an idea try to
secure this diagonal a 71 against checks
hmm even that seems to be wrong
hmm is it just a draw I mean that can be
perfectly glad with the drawing off tur
what the nonsense I played earlier what
if i move the a porn just for argument's
sake a 4d 4586 d3 let him promote and i
promote
I don't know not sure maybe this is
completely crazy but maybe I can still
try to to do something with this
yeah okay well Quincy 8 was a draw d3 a
66 is going to promote first and he's
got queen to d6 check it's probably
that's also drawn already that's also a
draw well at least we got four queens on
the board which is quite quite funny
yeah just promote and I promote on a
eight and then it's probably got to play
Queen d6 check and this will secure the
draw I'm not sure that he can try to win
it the beep onus is really strong
my thread is Queen g3 Wow
Quincy long time warning
hmm
that's a strong frame
I don't see I don't see some something
great here just to try to to cover
well white forfeits on time sure yeah I
should have just taken the draw I mean
it was lucky to get the drawer in any
case and its really funny the computer
just give sadly dead wrong so my blunder
was actually just a draw yeah I mean
it's it so of course just just bad play
because we can all the moves I'm not
better here just let's just say takes or
Quincy to this is just a slight edge for
white probably not great but better then
then being attached to the scale so it
needs to happen nothing I want to play
to draw that's really funny I computer
grease the senses all right yeah of
course Quincy seven is to draw already i
know but i wanted to to do more this is
this is service is losing quincy eight
is the last moment to secure the draw
yeah i can always play quincy eight and
then he must must give this perpetual
there is no check no choice he had it
was simply queen bee one is the killer
that they only move it's the only move
probably a yeah is it the only move not
losing actually maybe and it's only move
winning as well maybe if I don't know
after that I'm toast so I played it too
hard for when I didn't see Quinn be when
I couldn't calculate this I mean it was
a bit of a gamble and my idea was of
course if if he does not if he plays a
move like let's say nothing move here
and I thought I just draw back and play
a
play this okay maybe maybe not maybe
damn now the computer always points out
quincy fire funny enough I mean Jesus
check check check this is a perpetual
yeah most bit too i meant of course it
was completely idiotic to blunder this
piece I was simply overlooking that he's
got he's got this check neither hate her
they've just just just silly so it's
probably a deserved lost that this was a
draw in fact check was completely
coincidental I didn't plan any of it
alright so thanks for watching